on va voir si votre amitié c'est du
solide vous qui s'est le plus chaud là
il ya débat espèces dont non java si
c'est bon là j'ai eu beau essayer le
vert et dans l'autre sens profond du
doubs là je m'appelais patrie pays là où
ça va je suis français monsieur
respectez moi ça non je pense que c'est
moi clairement bien c'est bien la
volonté de dire la vérité est venu pour
longtemps que perdre mes cheveux
c'est une cata syrie fric mais regarde
mais la route est possible avec la
technique
j'ai fait un faux gel de me mettre
défaut de gras qui s'est le plus beau je
crois là c'est clair et ça fait dix ans
que c'est arrivé à des rames n'importe
quoi il a ainsi fait fiable il a les
traits parfaits dubos berbère et le
bauhb et douanes ont jailli garde de
beaux bédouins je le préfère au cas où
je pensais pas que ça tomberait social
voiture elle a placé des cartes de
bédouins qui s'est le plus drôle la
place il ya on teste pas vu pareil il ya
il nous faut les deux je pense qu'ils
s'équipent ostré - c'est moi c'est la
rouille l'algérie mais attention parce
que moi mais la cool qu'elle annule quoi
qu'il arrive il est là non mais je veux
dire à l'écriture au des touaregs et toi
tous les biais je suis un peu plus
dilettante ouest chez ceux qui tiennent
moins bien les alcools
c'est gravissime doublé du jour les
absences à l'écriture des fois j'arrive
à jal une clé compliqué là c'est qu'il
publie en d2 je pensais - ouais ouais
ouais c'est moi lui il est vraiment
arabique arabi je suis un biniou là
ouais c'est un biniou là pour laquelle
et moi je suis à moitié c'est vrai moi
tu sais qui a le plus besoin de l'autre
ils s'emmerdent ans a comme question
safran vers les bras moi j'ai plus envie
de toi par contre deux mois tu m'as dit
sitruk nom qui va se barrer en premier
je pense que c'est eric est déjà au pire
verdi et dans un décès non mais
ben oui mais je pense qu'il est plus
fragile qui c'est qui gagne le plus de
blur en solo sa guise et ans bruno sur
l'euro tu veux dire parce que le blog
baloch cartonne non je sais pas je pense
vraiment a deux atouts seul françois
frey pas beaucoup de zèle qui sait qu'à
l'appui jolis meubles de 2 g une
mallette magnifique algérienne ramsey
une magnifique italienne que je connais
et qui t'embrasse un mois six membres
et là ça va qui c'est qui pèse le plus d
dessus qui baissent de plus celui qui
pèse le plus l'autre
ramzy c'est incroyable ce qu'ils baisent
un labo embrouille chez matador
non mais c'est comme tous les arabes
c'est à dire beaucoup mais très rapide
d'accord il sait qu'il a la réputation
tombe qui sait qu'à baiser avec la plus
moche d2 au revoir à me faire avant
d'être mariée faire le reproche est fait
des vaches moi et pas le souvenir mais
était bourré mais bourré qui n'a rien
fait déjà ça va à qui sait qu'ils
voulaient pas venir ce soir
aucun on était contents jusqu'à ce qu'on
voit que la vache soit invitée avant
nous
chaque